よろしくお願いします
で あの 善心章はまあ説明してありました
今日あの これからなんですけど
えっとまあ善心章であの理解して欲しかったのは
この善心っていうのは結構明るい心っていうことで
活発的な心はまあ善心だと
で 人間っていうのは欲か怒りの感情で行動しているんだから
この結構ストレス溜まったり
行動力がどんどん消えていったりはするんで
で 行動力は完璧に消えるわけじゃないんだけど
あのだいたい怒りができると
それなりにいろんなことはできるんですよ
まあ怒りを持って人々が仕事をしたり
勉強したり いろんなことをやったりするんです
ただ怒りがあるんだから
人と喧嘩したり戦ったりしているだけではないんです
で 怒りを持ってよく頑張ったりする人々もいるし
まあどっちにしても まあどんな方向へ至っても
それによってその人は喜び
幸福を感じてるわけじゃないんです
人生は戦いになってるんだからね
で その戦いによって自分の希望通りに人生勝っても
それによってまた高慢が出たり
またそれによってまたトラブルを起こしたりして
結局ストレスばっかり溜まる人生になってしまうんですね
それから欲が生まれても同じことで
欲がある人は人のものを取ったり盗んだり
悪いことをしたりしてるだけではないんです
欲が生まれてきたら 欲の感情によってまた商売をしたり
家を建てたり 金を儲けたり
社会のためにいろんなことをやったりとかね
まあ名誉 有名になることやら人気が出ることやら
いろんなことを何でもしたりはします
で でも結果としては その人は結局はそれの行動によっていろいろストレス溜まって
まあ人生は苦しくなるんですね
幸福は感じないんですね
ですから この善心の場合はそうじゃなくて
幸福というものを感じるんですね
安らぎを感じる 楽ということを感じる
その辺でその差が理解してほしいんです
例えば あの人々が社会のためにいろんなことをしているんだと
それはまあ表向きではいいことであって
人々を助けてあげたり
いいことをしているんだという
表向きではいいことであって
それで我々には じゃあその人は善心でいいことをしているかどうかっていうことは判断ができないんですね
判断したい場合は判断する必要は全くないんだけど
まあ大体自分のことだったらいくらか判断した方がいいんですからね
で そういういいことをしていても
その人は本当にまあ喜びを感じていますかと
喜びを感じる場合も これまた区別しなくちゃいけない
まあ我ながらよくやってるぞというふうな
このもうなんか高慢感じてるならば
それは喜びじゃないんです
で 自分のことを威張って考えたら
それも我々は喜びだと誤解しやすいんですね
大変喜んでいるんだと
それでもなく ただ単に美しい喜びをね
誰から見ても何も思わない喜び
例えば子供たちが遊んで喜んでいるのを見て
誰でも嫌だとか憎たらしいとか思わないんですね
純粋に喜びを感じているんだから
そういうふうな感じで
その人が喜びを感じているかないかと
もし喜びを感じているならば
それは善行為であって
それから自分の仕事によってすごくストレス溜まったり
また嫌になったり やる気を失ったりという状態になってくると
また善心ではないということはまあ言えるんですね
ですから この善心の働きっていうのはそういうことではなくて
本当にストレスは溜まらないし
喜びを感じる 幸福を感じて生きていくことはできるんですね
ですから その場合はこの怒りとむさぼりの衝動とは違う
怒りがない状態でむさぼりがない状態
で 怒りとむさぼりがなく
人々はそれでもいわゆる何の別に何か得ようという
あ こういうことをして
私はこうなりたい ああなりたい
これぐらい得をしたい
これぐらい儲かりたいという気持ちはない
それは欲がないということ
こんなことをして ああいう人をやっつけてやりますとかね
もうこういうこういう社会情勢を私は破壊して壊して新しいものを作り直しますとか
そういう怒りの衝動もないし
そういうもう別にどうったことなく
まあいいことだからしましょうという
すごい明るい気持ちで行動すると
それは善心であるということは理解してほしいんです
ですから このまあまあわかりやすく言えばそれくらいのことで
まあ人間にはそういう善心の状態もたまたまなんですけど
生まれるんです たまたま誰でも経験しているんですね
よくいろんな仕事をしたんだけど
別に疲れたっていうことはないんだと
で 嫌だとか疲れた大変だとかという気持ちが何ともなく
仕事を終わっても気持ちいいと
すごい元気と 仕事をしている時でも
すごく気持ちよく 明るく
よくできましたというふうな経験というのはいくらでもありますし
だからそういう時はもう専心なんですね
別に何か希望あったわけでもないし
ただ何か壊そうと 何か悪いものを直してやろうという怒りがあったわけでもないし
ただその時 それをしてあげたということだけで
で まあ分かりやすい例で言えば
たまに例えば幼稚園にいる
行く子供がいるならば
お母さんたちが毎日幼稚園に行かなくちゃいけない
その場合は幼稚園に色々催し物やいろんなもの
出来事があったりするんで
お母さんたちが集めていろんなことをするんですね
する場合は 見えるのは見えで
あの人よりは自分がやらなくちゃいけないとかね
言って いろんな行動しちゃうと
みんなより自分がもう派手に
何て言いますか 目立つようなことをしなくちゃいけないという感じで
いろんなことをすると
その本人はすごくそこでまたストレス溜まったりするし
他の人々からもすごく嫌に思ってしまうし
大変だ 忙しいんだとか
もう幼稚園のことでいかがですと自分にまた文句言ったりするし
もう一人の母さんお母さんが幼稚園だから面白いとね
子供たちのことだから
みんなそれで楽しがるんだから
まあやりましょうという感じで
それ何の何の 誰かに 誰かによく
誰かより自分の方がよく頑張るんだと認めてほしくもなく
もう誰か誰かけなしてやろうではないかという気持ちもなく
じゃあみんな楽しくやってるんだからやりましょうという気持ちでやっちゃうと
別にストレス溜まることはないし
その出来事を本人にとってすごい楽しい
終わってから すごく楽しかったと
後からも楽しい ですから
同じ行動でも怒りでやることもできるし
むさぼりでやることもできるし
専心性で同じ行動をすることもできるし
ですから 怒りとむさぼりですると
当然ストレス溜まってすごく嫌な気持ち
自分硬くなっていくんですね
どんどんどんどん硬くなっていく
で 普通不尽で 不尽でやる場合は
自分は硬くなるわけじゃなくて
どんどん自分が柔らかくなって
柔軟性が心に生まれてくる
その区別して そういう状態をちゃんと理解したところで
私たちに 今私たちは専心で行動しているんですか？あるいは不専心性の影響で行動しているんですか？ということは理解できるんですね
不専心性でのエネルギーで行動していると
確実に自分が硬くなってきて
柔軟性がなくなってきて
どんどんどんどんストレス溜まって
最終的には活 何と言いますか
活発性はなくなってストップになるんです
これ以上はできないというところに必ずしもなるんです
不専心性の場合は どこまでも行動できるということはないんです
で 専心性の場合はそういうことではなくて
どこまででも行動できる
明るさをどんどん増やしていく
ですから この不専のエネルギーにはもうリミットがありまして
それ以上は強くならないというリミットがあるんですね
専心性にはリミットはないんです
どこまででも強調することを
強くすることはできるんです
その差も理解しておいてください
例えば怒りっていうのはどこまででも強烈に怒れるんじゃないかと
それはそうはできないんです
怒りが生まれるたびに体硬くなってきて
体に毒が生まれてきて
心も硬くなってきて で
最終的にはもうそれ以上は行動できないというところで終わらなくちゃいけない
まあ強烈に怒ったら その人はその場で死んでしまう
それ以上進めなくなっちゃうんですね
欲の場合も あまり強烈に欲が生まれたら人は死ぬんです
もう耐えられなくなる
ないんだから毒ですからね
ですから まあここまでということは決まってるんです
で 善心性の働きの場合はそういう風な決まってない
ここまでって ですから
いい方向へ行くならば
いくらでもいい方向へ進むことはできるんです
ですから 人間というのは
この怒りと貪りで行動するのは
まああんまりにもバカバカらしいことで
あまりにも無知なことで
何の意味もないんです
ですから わずかな貪りでも
わずかな怒りでも何の役にも立たない
まあ無駄なんですね ですから
この善心性を作って そのエネルギーで働けば
いくらでもいつでも幸福を感じられることは可能です
ですから まあこの我々の狭い考え方は捨ててしまって
もっとより幅広く物事を普遍的に物事を考えて
もっと他の言葉で言い換えれば
自我を捨てて 私という概念を置いておいて
もう普通に行動すれば
人間には限りなく行動力生まれてくる
限りない幸福が生まれてくるということで
そういう理解は この善心性の勉強から
アビダンマから出てくるドゥートコロンテスとして理解しています
で 次に言えるのは このそういうふうに行動しても
智慧と まあ慈悲と智慧っていうのはそんな簡単に生まれません
ですから このすごい行動力ある明るい人であっても
まあ慈悲があるかというと
慈悲がないかもしれません
慈悲がないということは
悪い意味悪い人という意味ではなくて
別にまあ自分でいいことをしているだけであって
もう別に人のことを気にしないとかね
他の生命のことはまああまり気にしない
気にしないというのは迷惑をかけるという意味ではないんだからね
で まあそれぐらいのことで
ですから その上 慈悲の慈しみの心
だいたい慈悲っていうのは簡単に生まれますけど
怒り蓋ちゃえばそこにあるのは慈悲なんですけど
で カルナという カルナっていうのはこの苦しんでいる人々をもうちょっと何かしてあげましょうということ
それはちょっとプラスアルファとして自分が行動しなくちゃいけない
別にそれぞれ生命は独立して生まれているんだから
我々は何かしてあげる必要はないんです
どんな生命でも自分のカルマを持って生まれてきて
自分のカルマによって死んでしまっちゃうし
自分の行為によって自分の輪廻を決めているんだから
私に関係あるわけじゃないんです
人がすごい幸福だと言ったって
それはまあほら 感謝しろという権利もないし
人は不幸だからといって
じゃあ何とかしてあげなくちゃっていう
別に関係ないんです 人は幸福であろうと不幸であろうが
それはその人のこないだからね
でもそれ それはそれで置いておいていいならば
それはそれに別に不善ということではないんですけど
やっぱり不幸な人を見たら
やっぱり放っておけないんだと
なんか自分にできることはして
その人をなんとか幸福になるようにしましょうという
人の苦しみをなくすような行動っていうのは
やっぱり余分に考えなくちゃいけない善心性なんですね
ということは 人はいいことをしている
心が幸福 善心だよと言っても
必ずしもカルナというものあるわけじゃない
カルナっていうのは別に育てなくちゃいけないこと
そうするとカルナも生まれてくる
次に出てくるムディタも同じことで
ムディタっていうのはこの正反対なことで
カルナとムディタは同じ心に一緒には生まれません
カルナっていうのは苦しんでいる人々を助けたくなる心の優しさ
ムディタっていうのは人々の幸福を見て共感できる心の優しさ
人々は成功していく 幸福になっていく
それで嫉妬しないで 自分も正直な心で
あ 良かったと共感をする
で あの まあインド文化では全部この母の心に例えていて
母には自分の子供に対してはそういう全ての感情があるんだと
その時その時 子供が苦しんだり悩んだりすると
病気になったりすると
もうとにかく助けてあげたくなる
子供が喜んで幸福になってくると
すごく自分が自分のことのように喜んだりする
何の微かな嫉妬も入らないんですね
現代社会では子供に嫉妬する人もいますけど
まあこういう理想的な母であるならば
もう微かな嫉妬も入らない
子供は自分を乗り越えてどんどん成長すると
それをまたもう一生懸命喜んだりするということはもあります
それモディタということですから
同じ心で一緒に生まれませんね
人の苦しみを何とかしたいという気持ちと
人の幸福を見て共感するということは
働きは全く違うんです
ですから 一緒の心 一つの心に慈悲喜捨全部生まれるわけじゃないんです
一つしか生まれません
慈か悲か喜か捨 どっちかなんですね
ですから その瞑想にしたっても
慈悲の瞑想というのは即興で言うんだけど
本当はメッター カルナ
モディタ ウペッカーという4種類の瞑想なんです
全く別々な瞑想なんです
生命に関する瞑想ということで
一つのカテゴリに入れてますけど
生命と自分の関係はどう持つべきかということで
4つの方法はありますと
4つから1つ選ばなくちゃいけないんですね
実践する場合は  4つも実践しても構いませんだけど
いっぺんに 2つはできない
ですから なぜならば この
あの 何て言いますか そのfunction
その機能が違うんです
マイトリ メッターの機能っていうのは
ただ友情の感情だから
それほど関わりを持つということではないんです
友情を持って まあ生命に接すると
病棟とおなじみなんですね
病棟ではないかと で そういう感じで生きることです
悲の場合は まあカルナの場合
やっぱり人が苦しんでいることを発見しなくちゃいけない
人の苦しみを発見して
それを何とかしてあげようということだから
友情とはものすごい違う
それから喜びのモディタの場合も
喜ぶことだから やっぱり人の幸福のところ
人のいいとこを見なくちゃいけない
人のいいとこを見て 自分がすごく喜びを感じると
どっちでも心の優しさなんですね
生命に対する 生命に対して友情を持つこともすごい優しい心なんですよ
動物見ても まあみんな同じ仲間ではないかと思う人が優しいんです
野良猫 野良犬に対しても
同じ みんな一緒に生きてる仲間ではないかと
この地球の生き物ではないかと
私も一つの生き物で そちらのもう一人の生き物で
ただそれだけではないかというふうに本気で
考える人は素晴らしく優しい人なんですね
とりあえず宗教で言ってるんだから野良猫を嫌とは思わないよというのはもうすごい無理があるんですよ
そういうのはまあ宗教を信仰している人々がやっていることで
それは無理があるんです
宗教と関係なく 心から湧いてくる
自然に湧いてくるエネルギーでなければいけません
お釈迦様がおっしゃったんだから
やっぱりもう本当の気持ちは嫌なんですけど
それでも頑張って優しくしましょうというのは
そういうのはすごい無理がありますよ
どこかでもひどい目に遭いますから
で その人も大変優しいし
人の生命の苦しみを見て何とかしたがる人もものすごく優しいんですね
何のことなく自分にできることをしてあげると
で 喜びを感じる人も それまた心優しいんですね
生命に対して 人々の命を幸福に
元気で頑張っているのを見て
ああ良かった 良かったと
というふうに共感する
共感できることは大変いいこと
まあ例えばこのいろんなこの芸術の世界で
いろんな人々はいろんな形で自分の芸術能力を発表したりするんですね
歌やら絵やら踊りやら
音楽やらいろんなことで
それを見ている人々は
その人々の才能を見て
ああ素晴らしいんではないかと
拍手したり褒めてあげたりすると
やっぱり互いにそれ気持ちいいんですね
で 漫才師がね 一生懸命公演やっても誰も笑ってくれないと
あまりまあいい雰囲気ではないんですね
でもその人はまあ自分は聞き慣れていることで聞き上げちゃっても面白くないかもしれませんだけど
それでもその人の才能を感じると
共感できるところはいくらでもありますよ
ですから この人はこれぐらい才能を持ってるんだと
これからどんどん成長するだろうと
ということを見ると また自分に共感できる
そうすると褒めてあげることもできるし
ですから その場合 お互いに大変気持ちいいし
お互いに成長するんですよ
我々が拍手をして褒めてあげると
そちらのそちら側も成長するし
我々も立派な人間になって成長する
ですからムディターも素晴らしい人間持つべき感情なんですね
で その人も優しいことには変わりはないんです
で ウペクシャーっていうのはメッターと同じなんです
友情と同じなんです 友情の場合はレベルちょっと低いし
ウペクシャーの場合はもうレベル高いというふうに言っても過言ではない
別に高い低いというわけじゃなくて
波として見ると 友情だからお互いに怒ったり喧嘩したりすることもできるし
で ウペクシャーの人はそこまでいかないんですね
例えば全ての生命は平等だと友達ではないかと思うと
犬に邪魔される 犬が邪魔するともう喧嘩できるので
あんた何やってるんですかと
いい加減にせんかと言えるんです
で それは本当に友情ある場合はそれは聞いてくれますけどね
で ウペクシャーの場合はそういうこともしようとしない
放っておくんですね で
みんなそれぞれ自分の生き方をやってるんだから
まあいいんじゃないかと
そういう理解というぐらいのことなんですね
生命のことを理解している
ですから自分が落ち着いて理解しているんだから
それはシャというふうな状態なの
それ4つも心の優しさ
一言で言えば心の優しさ
生命に対する人間持つべき感情
ですから  4つも育てるならばそれは素晴らしいんだけど
いっぺんに 4つ育てることはできない
その場でその場で考えて
その4つを育てる ですから
今はメッターだと 今はカルマ実践しなくちゃいけない
今はムディタ実践しなくちゃいけない
今はウペッカーだというふうに
その状況に応じて自分の実践方法を変えればいいし
心の感情から見ても 時々自分が友情を感じやすい時もありまして
カルマを感じやすい時もあります
心も波がありますから
そのどんなその時の状態によってムディタを感じやすい時もありまして
それ自分の気分次第になりますね
自分の気分によってもこの瞑想というのは変わるんですよ
ですから このムディタ
人のいいことを思う 感じて喜びを感じられる気分だったら
ムディタの瞑想をすると
友情の気分だったらメッターの瞑想をすると
もうちょっと自分も落ち着いて
心にそれほど荒い波がなく
智慧があるような状態だったら
ウペッカーの実践をするというふうに
自分気分次第にも瞑想を変えるし
それから自分の置かれている環境によっても
慈悲喜捨の瞑想を変えるのは正しいやり方
で その中でこのメッターとウペッカー
別にこの善心所では扱ってないんですね
それはこの普遍的な心性の中にあるんだと
メッターっていうのは怒りがない状態だから
怒りがない状態だから
怒りがない状態だけ感情的に強くなってくるとメッターになる
ウペッカーっていうのはタットラマッジャタタという心性だと思いますけど
で その このタットラマッジャタタという心性が生まれてくると
それが強くなるとウペッカーとして扱うと
で カルナーとムディターはまた別な感情で
それは別に修行しなくちゃ生まれてこない
ですから 明るい人の心に人を助けてあげようという気持ちが生まれてくると
カルナーもあるんだと
人のことを見て 生命のことを見て喜びを感じる時はムディターはあるんだと
ですから その二つはこの共情心所なんて言って
共情心所の中に入ってないんですね
別にカテゴリに入れてるんです
それから一番大事なポイントは智慧なんですね
パンニャーなんですね
パンニャーはまた別なカテゴリに入れてるんです
パンニャーはまた別に育てなくちゃいけない
いくら人はすごい善心所だけ利口動してるんだとか言っても
パンニャーあるわけじゃないんです
パンニャーはわざと育てなくちゃいけないことで
仏教でパンニャーっていうのは
見るものはそのまま見るだけでパンニャーではないんです
見るものをそのまま見ただけでパンニャーが現れないんです
なぜならば 見る 聞く 感じる
考えるという行動によって
物質のものごとの生滅変化は見えないんです
あるものは感じるんであって
ないものは感じるわけじゃないでしょうに
ないっていうことは感じたというのは
それはおかしいんですよ
何か見えるものがあると見えるんであって
見えるものがないと見えないんですからね
そこに心は働いてないんです
ですから 心っていうのはある
有の状態しか感じないんです
ですから 我々の心の中
いつでもあるという無ではなくて有の世界にいるんですね
ですから 簡単に何か説明する場合は
有の次元で説明するとみんな理解する
よくわかりましたと で
例えばもう神ですか GOD
ですか そういうGODという概念なんかを使って説明すると
ああ分かりやすいこと
分かりやすいこと で  [笑い]ですから
この例えば人間にカルマを説明すると思っちゃうと理解が難しい
神様はそう決まってるんだから
あんたは神様に言われた通りに設計された通りにあんたは思い存分頑張ればいいんじゃないか
いちいち文句言わないでと
と言ったところで その人はやっぱりこの宇宙の法則を認めて
こういう法則の中で私はこういうものだと
そのシステムの中でどう生きていればいいかということはもう簡単に理解できますよ
ヒンドゥー教で言っている神はあなただよと
じゃあそれだったらなんで私は神にならないかというと
私は私だと思っているんだから神にならないんだと
私はという概念は完璧に消えたところで
それは神の状態だと そういうふうに簡単に説明する
川は川でいる限りは色々トラブルがあるんだが
海に入ったらどんな川かはさっぱり関係ないんだと
ですから 川といえば自我があって
どんな川かというと ガンジス川かヤムナ川か
もうサラッスティーかハスラワティーかどっちか
それはそれ インドの川の名前なんですけど
隅田川でも色々川がありますけど
で それ特色があったりして
いろんな問題なんです
それで海に行ったらただ海であって
海の水を見て あ これはジャムナ川の水だよと
これはガンジス川の川の水だよと
これはもう紛れもなく隅田川の水だよっていうことは絶対言えないんですね
ですから 自我を捨てたところで神になるんだと
別に何かする必要はないんだと
自分の自我を捨てるだけで十分だよっていうふうに言っても
そうすると理解しやすいんですよ
それは全部有の世界の説明なんですね
ですから 智慧があると仏教では言わないんです
いくら理解できても いくらそこら辺で修行して自我をなくしたような体験があっても
それは智慧というふうには言わないんですね
何か一部欠けているんだと
そこまで別に反対しているわけじゃないんです
で そこまで仏教の話も一緒に行きますけど
進んでいきますけどね
自我捨てるのは それは言葉だけで言うならば
それは全く同じことを言ってますけどね
もうちょっと一歩進んで何か一つ言うんですね
認識の世界で有しか認識できないんだと
だから現代宗教にしたっても
古代のヒンドゥ教にしたっても
他の古い宗教にしても
全部徹底していた有論なんですね
無論はほとんどない 無の論ではない
全部有の論で それは人間が何か体験して喋ってるんだから
有論であることは当たり前なんです
我々もいつでも体験しているんですね
いろんなことを 聞くということも体験なんですよ
見るということも体験なんです
考えるということも体験なんですね
ですから 聞くためには
音というものは耳に触れなくちゃいけないんです
音というものは耳に触れなきゃ
そこに聴覚というものはありえない
聴覚という体験は生まれません
ですから 我々の経験全ては現象が有の状態にある時生まれるものなんです
ですから 人間の一切の経験は有の経験
有の経験なんです そういうことで
じゃあ智慧が生まれるためにどうしようかと
もうちょっとさらにそれを探らなくちゃいけないんですね
いわゆる物事はもう波であって
有と無と両方の波が持っているんだと
であれは理屈でもいくらかは考えられますよ
物は変化するんだからね
あるものが 例えばAという現象の形をとっているんだと
名前で言うならばAと言えるんだと
それはまた変化して B
という名前を付けられるような現象に変わるんだと
そうするとAという現象は必ずしも死ななくちゃいけないんですね
そうでないとBが生まれませんだから
ですから そのAが消えた瞬間感じてないんですね
我々にはAがあった 今はBがあると
それだけで考えてしまう
赤ちゃんがいたならば
赤ちゃんが死ななきゃ子供にならないんです
子供は死ななきゃもう青年にならないんです
いつ死んでいくかって
それはわからないんですね
全然わからない 感じない
経験できない で まあ並ですからね
まあ例えば赤ちゃんで一年
二年 三年 ずっと同じ状態でいて
六年目の誕生日にいきなり大きくなるんだったら
もうその瞬間つかめるかもしれませんだけど
そうはないんだから ものすごい速いんだから
生滅変化は なかなかつかまれません
今のうちはそういう速く変化といえば地震ぐらいかな
何も前兆なしにいきなり
まあそれでもまあ細かい弱い余震というかね
地震いくつか出てきて
それから大きな地震が現れたりしますけどね
まあそれまた決まってないんです
いきなりの余震も何もなく
大きい地震が現れる可能性もありますけど
その時はまあ瞬間に変わることはわかりますけど
その時でもやっぱり変わったものは見えるんであって
変わっていくということは見えないんですね
変わっている状態を見ていても
我々には有しか見えないんですね
ですから 我々にはわざわざとすべては生滅変化しているんだ
すべては無常だ まあ実体はないんだと
どんなものにも変化するんだから
そういう方向へ強引に思考を持っていかなくちゃいけない
そうすると有も無も両方理解できて
有の極論にも陥れませんし
無という極論にも陥れませんし
すべては因縁によって生まれていくというパティッチサンパですか
この因果法則にという中道に人は行くんです
それによって人間に智慧が生まれて
解脱することができるんです
ですから この自我を捨てて神と一体になるということは
まあもう最高な有の世界にある最高な状態なんですけど
心は完全に智慧がつかまってないんですね
有の世界ではそれは最高の状態なんですけど
それでも人間得られませんね
すごい執着があるんだから
私を捨てられませんと
私が捨てたら何ももう何の意味もないのではないかと思っちゃうんですね
私が悟りたいと 私で仏の一になりたいんだと
それだったらもう絶対なれないんだからね
私が捨てたらそれは それだけのことで
それで悟りたい私がそこにないんだから
そこで問題終わりなんです
で ですから この私というものを捨てない限りは
この梵我一如の状態もね
体現できませんだけど
有の世界ではそれは最高の状態ですけど
やっぱり心の波動 エネルギーから見ると
やっぱり有でいたいという欲望が
渇愛が もう無明がね 渇愛というよりは無明が働いてるんですね
ですから また帰ってくる
また現象の世界に帰ってくる
現象がまたその状態から生まれてくるということになるんですね
で そこまでは人間には理解できませんだからね
宗教はそこで割ってるんです
仏教は初めからその次元から始めているんです
だから 人間のギリギリの考えられる世界のギリギリのところから仏教の世界でスタートするんです
まあ聞いてればですから
難しいかもしれません
無常の論というのは一番難しいんです
まあそこまで別に考えなくても結構ですけど
一応ただ専心で生きているんだからといって
カルマとムディタは生まれないことと
智慧というのは生まれないことだけ理解してください
カルマとムディタはプラスアルファとして修行しなきゃ
実践しなきゃいけない
智慧もよくに考えなくちゃいけないものなんですね
人に優しくする それはいいことですけど
それで喜んで止まるんじゃなくて
まあ人に優しくしたっても
それは結局すぐ消えてしまうんだと
その瞬間だけだよと その人にはそれで永久的に何か助けてあげたわけでもないし
自分が何か永久的な何か得たわけでもないんだと
お腹が空いている人にご飯をあげるんだと
その人はその時ご飯食べてすごく喜んだんだからといって
それで永遠にその人を追っかけて
あんたがその間喜ばせてあげたんではないか
それで満腹でしょうとか
そんなことはできないしね
まあ無知な人はそうするんです
ちょっとちっぽけないいことをして
もういちいちその人を追って追って
まあそれで感謝してもらおうとかね
という性格の人々いますけどね
何の意味もないんで それは無知だからね
結局無知な人がやってるいいことにもそんなに結果がないんですよ
たとえ大金を寄付したってもね
根底は無知だったらね
もうほとんどわずかな結果で終わっちゃうんですね
やっぱり智慧があると
その分は結果が着確実にあるんです
ですから まあいいことしたっても
それはまあその瞬間のことやと
もう全部消えていくんだと
という無常の方向も考えていかなくちゃいけない
そういうふうに考えると
それに智慧もプラスアルファとして生まれてくる
智慧っていうのは一番大事な心性で
それはヴィパッサナーの実践によって生まれてくるんですね
ヴィパッサナーといっても
ちゃんと見ることだから
やっぱりちゃんと何を見るんですかというと
アビダンマで言ってる原子次元で一番細かいところで物質と心と心性がつかまって見える
そうするとそれはすぐすぐもう消えていくということはわかる
例えば怒りという心性瞑想でつかまったら
あ これは怒りだと で 次から次の心を見ると
全く怒りと全く性質の違う心性があるということがわかるんですね
それでちょっと前の自分の心と今の自分の心は全く違うのではないかと
生まれ変わってる状態ではないかとわかるんですね
その時初めていくらかこの人間の物質の流れっていうのは
噴水のように川のようなもので
実体はないと その瞬間の水を見て
あ 噴水だ 川だと言うんであって
別に川という実体はありませんと
噴水という実体はありませんということはわかるし
それがわかってくると
心は上手になってね 鋭くなって
無の瞬間を体験できるようになるんです
無の瞬間を体験したらもうしっかりするんです
もうなるほど正しかったと
自分の今までの努力はという
このヴィパッサナーの悟りというのは
まあ現代言葉に入れ替えて言うと
この無という瞬間を体験してみろということなんです
有と無の流れでずっと有だけ見られるようにプログラムされてるんです
それぞれのプログラムを全部組み
新しく書き換えて無を体験できるようになる
なったらその人はもう二度と騙されないし
無を見たんだから いつでもその人に有無両方見ようと思えば見える
ですから 悟りということはもう最終的なものなのです
ヴィパッサナーから得られる悟り
その人には神は思うとか
そんなお話はもう子供のうわごとみたいなもので
もう何の意味もなくなっちゃう
じゃあ心性の話はだいたいそれぐらいで
アビダンマもこれからはもうアビダンマはコースをやめるか終了するかっていうことを考えていますけども